[Musique]
super heureux super fier parce que on va
se fendre poitiers et avoir une une
structure comme ça dans sa ville ça fait
ça fait du bien ça fait plaisir je pense
que ça va aussi dynamiser un peu le
département la région la ville donc
super content
pareil super heureux ça va être un super
moment vendredi pour moi il y aura toute
la famille tous les amis d'enfance donc
ça va être ça a été un moment un moment
émotion on va dire mais il ya quand même
un match dont on va falloir faire
abstraction de tout ça
j'espère j'espère on verra ça on verra
ça vendredi
c'est dur parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses à faire il n'y a pas beaucoup de
temps de repos il n'y a pas beaucoup de
temps pour pour soi mais c'est aussi du
plaisir c'est une passion donc à chaque
fois qu'il ya possibilité de des clichés
ben on kiffe tout simplement
à j'aimerais bien on va falloir vendre
beaucoup de valeur vend beaucoup
d'albums
mais non c'est clair que ce serait ce
serait super beau c'est rare m